Okay. Let's look at more heavy duty stuff, Appstats.
Appstats is a function that allows you to get
extensive information on how API functions are called by
your applications. This is used to profile your application. You
do this by inspecting the API calls made by
your application to, for example, Datastore in Memcache. And
then you could use the information to optimize your
application. For example, you can find opportunities to minimize latency
by caching data. It can also be used to reduce
or bundle API calls. Appstats can also help you reduce
cost if you go beyond the free tier, as it
can display the cost associated with different API calls. So let's
see how you can use Appstats. But first of all,
you can enable the eight I tracing through configuration. So
there is no need to make any modifications to your
application. And when you have run your application, it is possible
to access the profiling information using a URL. You can
see how to do both of those things in the
instructor notes. So let's look at the information that apps
will provide you with. First of all, Appstats has a
dashboard screen where you will see all the different data
available. So, let's look at each section separately. The RPC
stats table shows statistics information for each remote procedure call
made by your application. So, here you can see, for example,
Datastore get operations. You can see the number
of calls, the cost for the calls. And the
percentage cost for the calls. This page also displays
other calls, for example Memcache Get or Datastore RunQuery.
That's the RPC stats table, very useful information. The
path stats table shows similar information but it is
grouped from the perspective of your code instead. So
here we can see that our query conference makes
calls to Datastore Get, and Datastore RunQuery. The request
history table shows information about a specific request that
was made. Here, for example, query conference was executed
at this time and made call to these API
functions. This table also has statistics for register for
conference, and get profile. The RPC timeline graph shows
when specific RPC calls were made and how long
the request took to process. So here you can see
that get OAuth_user took six milliseconds, followed by
Datastore begin transaction. Four milliseconds, then two GET
operations towards Datastore, followed by a PUT operation.
And then finally, the transaction commit. So this graph
shows you the sequence of API calls, and
how long each took to execute. And of course,
you can also see your complete request latency.
That's appstats, a great way to understand your application
behavior and optimize it.